what is the question
that was a rumor
i'm gonna leave with like however many
puppies they have
hi i am tessa thompson i am here with
buzzfeed and i am about to be here with
a lot of puppies which i'm really
excited about and i'm going to answer
your questions or i'm going to try it's
going to be hard
[Music]
oh
oh my god they're so floppy
hi
hi
[Music]
probably doing an underwater fight scene
with tandaway
and we shot in mexico
so it was like
being on like twisted vacation
[Music]
like sometimes she'll like look with her
eyes before
moving her head which was
really fun to try to like capture
um
the cat to try to capture the spirit of
uh her
yeah they're just the way she moved and
then to make it my own i think you know
it was sort of um
easy because like it was me doing it so
it was gonna be my own if that makes
sense
this sounds kind of
kinky but i don't mean it to be
probably michael b jordan because he
could like work out for me he could take
my body for a month honestly and
you know help it
it's very west world there's probably
like splintered group chats like i have
one i think with evan
rachel wood and james marsden and then
hand away she's a good texter she's a
lot of memes with her
what is the question
oh my god
the hardest part sometimes is just how
mean she
is
and i love my castmates so much being in
that space sometimes
is challenging
[Music]
yes yes yes yes body parts and i also
have like a special
suit which i think actually you might
see
in the finale
i technically think i might have
auditioned for a host for an original
host on westworld but then then they
called me and asked me to read
something else and this time i knew it
was for a human so i might have
these two i auditioned for cloverfield
as an actor you just forget all the
things that you auditioned for that you
didn't get
you just forget them right away
[Music]
mark ruffalo he's my favorite person
[Laughter]
i would be stuck anywhere with with mark
ruffalo he's so funny i feel like he
could keep you really calm and also he
he's the person i just met i haven't
gotten to see him a lot relative to
other people in the mcu so i could i
could deal with some elevator time i
might like
get an elevator stuck on purpose so i
could hang out with mark ruffalo for the
afternoon does this work on puppies this
works on kids
i definitely try to perform everything
you know to various degrees of success
they don't like to let you like smash on
things and i have an amazing
stunt devil named tara mackin and we
love to work together work together and
everything you know what was the most
fun christian bale doing that it
reminded me actually when i had a fight
scene with kate planchette because
you're so i'm so excited to work
opposite those actors and then you're so
nervous because you're like don't just
don't hit them don't hit them don't hit
them
after every take
christian would be like are you all
right he was playing like such a scary
bad guy and then and then he was like so
considerate it was really cute
this is my favorite part oh you're cute
god you're cute my favorite part is how
much we get to improv how how silly it
is to
make the movies feels like a lot of play
and i love working with
with chris so much
i think i think i mean i always knew
this about
natalie because we're friends and have
gotten to hang so much socially and and
work together and other things she's so
funny but it was i think learning the
extent of that while making flower love
and thunder was really fun and i think
will surprise
audiences and then christian i didn't
know what to expect i had never met him
but he's so nice he's like so
um sweet and also very very funny which
i think might it might surprise
fans
coleman domingo
or niecey nash she's really good at
facetiming
she she'll still answer her facetime
actually colin domingo is the one that
told me nuc nashville always answer
facetime and then we did it and she did
um cheers
i would have loved to guest star on
cheers
or the golden girls that that would be
so cool shows now maybe succession that
would be fun
[Music]
the thing i was so interested in is um
that he would be so like in character
and then he could shift so easily
into directing and he did this really
cool thing where instead of saying cut
when he'd be in the scene you would just
see him really subtly do this
and that was really cool
oh the wildest room i've ever heard
about myself uh i think everyone knows
that was a rumor and definitely not true
i didn't get to really um
welcome jonathan
too much because he was mostly doing
fight stuff but
i think you know a lot i think a lot of
like male hugging
which i just like to watch
[Music]
i would like to see actually i once
voiced a dog
um with justin throw and he was my puppy
mate and so i'd like to see him do a
puppy interview
thanks buzzfeed for giving me my new
puppy
i'm never leaving her and make sure to
watch uh the uh westworld show on hbo
and these puppies are adoptable at north
shore animal league america
[Music]
you